[Music]
on this monday night calls to search for
all
lost indigenous children the discovery
of unmarked graves at a former kamloops
residential school lead to demands for a
plan to find
all the buried children the deaths of
these children
have brought it all home and i think
it's just the tip of the iceberg
their deaths undocumented but not
unknown the trauma
generations of indigenous families carry
and the calls to act
as if they were your children managing
manitoba's overflowing icus we have
absolutely over taxed our icu staff
more covet 19 patients flown out of the
province
as new admissions keep coming political
uncertainty israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu's rivals unite
to unseat him and it's hockey night for
health workers
fans in the stands as the leafs and
halves face off
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
across the country symbols of mourning
and grief from parliament hill
to provincial legislatures flags were
lowered to half-mast
vigils held and shoes lined up to
represent
the up to 215 children whose remains
have been found in unmarked graves
on the grounds of a former residential
school in kamloops
reopening old wounds for indigenous
families
torn apart
it is a great open secret that our
children lie
on these properties of former schools
an open secret that canadians can no
longer
look away from
the truth and reconciliation commission
identified 3
200 deaths of children in residential
schools but the real number
is higher so many records are lacking
names and genders weren't recorded
parents weren't informed the chair of
the commission murray sinclair has said
the number of children who died could be
as high as
six thousand there were about 140
residential schools across canada
indigenous children were forcibly taken
from their homes
prohibited from speaking their language
or learning their culture
there are now calls to find all the lost
children not just the more than 200 who
have been discovered
thanks to ground penetrating radar in
unmarked graves
in kamloops there is a collective sense
they and their families deserve
more than just lowered flags and empty
political promises
heather yorick's west has our top story
tonight
allen knockwood was a young child when
he was taken from his family
and forced to live in a residential
school we were
punished for any
hint of disobedience
i was 9 years old and they took my hands
out like this and i had 10
hits on each hand with the strap
and it caused my hands to swell up to
the point where i couldn't move them
still knockwood says he considers
himself lucky
he survived at least 215 children in
kamloops did not
and across the country indigenous
community members believe there are many
more victims
that remain unaccounted for there was a
lot of first degree murder
murders that happened in those schools
so it triggered a lot of emotions
for thousands of people right across
this country in saskatchewan the
federation of sovereign indigenous
nations
say it's time to conduct radar ground
searches at residential school sites
across the province
near calgary the sixth sick nation is
asking an investigation to be carried
out at every site across the country
i had to take a drive and
have a good cry out of that remembering
but also
being grateful to these children
that were found and the probability of
finding children here too
around this school the past few days
have been traumatizing for survivors
like butch wolfleg
remembering not only those who died at
the schools but in the years
since they came home their way of
dealing with this trauma is through
addictions dulling the pain
and a lot of them died while they were
dulling the pain
speaking about such a painful past is
not easy
for many survivors it's not something
they often do
but there is also a deep need to ensure
these stories
are told so that moving forward there
can be peace and justice
that is just not possible without
accountability
and truth heather urex west global news
calgary
today bc premier john horgan addressed
the discovery at the former residential
school in kamloops
he says he was horrified when he heard
the news and says
making amends is the least his
government can do
we're proud people we've done
extraordinary things together but we've
also done
atrocious things together and
collectively we have a responsibility
to face that head-on and after the
discovery
of a mass grave in kamloops it's more
real now than ever before
there is renewed pressure on the federal
government to help find all the lost
graves of indigenous children who died
at residential schools
and this is far from the first call to
action as david aiken reports the
trudeau government is now being urged to
do more to fulfill key recommendations
made by the truth and reconciliation
commission
as a dad i can't imagine what it would
feel like to have my kids
taken away from me and as prime minister
i am appalled by the shameful policy
that stole
indigenous children from their
communities
campaigning to be prime minister in 2015
justin trudeau promised
he would implement all 94
recommendations
made by the truth and reconciliation
commission
including six that had to do with
missing children and burial information
things like creating a national register
of student deaths
a register of burial places and funding
burial ceremonies and commemorations
those calls to action have not been
fully implemented so that's the
frustration
like you have a report we don't want it
gathering
dust the commission did a lot of work to
figure out how many children died and
where they are buried but some work was
left undone
when the harper government turned down a
request by the commission
for an extra one and a half million
dollars to help locate
missing cemeteries it would not be until
2019
when the trudeau government set aside
funds about 34 million dollars
to implement the six commission
recommendations
on burial sites of children they need to
fully fund
the work that needs to be done to
identify the unmarked grades
of children across canada because there
are many many more
but as of this week the status of all
the commission recommendations involving
ottawa is
unfinished incomplete talks continue so
so far there's a lot of distance between
their statements
and their actions towards children and
we need to be watching carefully their
actions
we've got to grieve this moment but for
the federal government it's not good
enough to just
continue with symbolic gestures trudeau
responded to that monday
we promised concrete action and that's
how we'll support
survivors families and indigenous
peoples
now trudeau would not say what he means
by concrete action that could take a
couple of days to work out but
in the meantime mps agreed unanimously
to hold an urgent debate on this issue
tomorrow
donna david a lot of people say it's
time for
less talk more action advocates like
cindy blackstock say
one concrete action could be to end
these court battles involving
residential school survivors and
indigenous children what's the
likelihood of that
well i asked trudeau about that today
and it doesn't sound to me like the
government of canada is going to back
off
three court cases it has ongoing one of
those involves residential school
survivors at
st anne school in northern ontario and
this school by the way is a
school where they used an electric chair
to punish the kids and
saint anne survivors have had to go to
court to get canada to turn over
documents
about how the kids there were cared for
the other two cases involved care of the
current generation of indigenous kids
ottawa is appealing a couple of human
rights rulings one of those cases is in
court in a couple of weeks but
you're right advocates and some
parliamentarians say ottawa should just
drop all three of these legal cases and
get on with the task of caring for
survivors
and the current generation of indigenous
kids donna
all right david aiken thanks
the ndp leader jagmeet singh says the
federal government needs to make some
tough decisions about its commitment to
remedy the injustice of the residential
school system
and this was his answer when he was
asked what message he has for the
families
who lost children
i'm sorry
we're gonna fight for justice for you
so many people are at a loss for words
the school in kamloops was run by the
catholic church and there are renewed
calls for the church to apologize for
its role in the residential school
system
the pope has stopped short of doing that
today the president of the canadian
conference of catholic bishops released
a statement saying
i express our deepest sorrow for the
heart-rending loss of the children at
the former kamloops indian residential
school
as we see ever more clearly the pain and
suffering of the past
the bishops of canada pledged to
continue walking side by side with
indigenous peoples in the present
seeking greater healing and
reconciliation for the future
across the country personal stories are
being shared about the impact of
residential schools
we want to share a powerful speech
delivered by indigenous mp
romeo saginash was back in 2014 but it
still resonates today
he made the speech while calling for a
national inquiry into missing and
murdered indigenous women
and he recalled his own brother's death
in a residential school
let me tell you a little story mr
speaker
about a little boy named johnish who was
sent to residential school
in 1954 he was five years old
never came back apparently
died the first year he arrived in
residential school
his mom mr speaker his mom
never knew until after two years of his
death
his mom my mom
for 40 years never knew where johnny
was buried for 40 years mr speaker
and it is only by coincidence one day
that my sister
one of my sisters happened to be in the
area and someone told her
i know where your little brother is
buried
so after 40 years my sister filmed
the site where he was buried brought the
film back
to my mom to show her
i saw my mother cry many times
but the day she saw that video
i had never seen her cry that way
that's closure mr speaker
that's what we call closure
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experience
pain or distress as a result of their
residential school experience
they can call toll-free and speak in
confidence the number is 1-866-925-4419
impossible to keep up coming up
manitoba's intensive care units grapple
with a record caseload
of cobit 19 patients
manitoba has announced a major change to
its vaccine rollout
the province is now allowing vaccine
mixing so eligible manitobans who got a
first dose of astrazeneca
can get an mrna vaccine as their second
dose
the head of manitoba's rollout says the
decision was based on results from a
spanish study
it hoped to have data from a major uk
study as well but that was delayed and
dr joss reimer says the province could
not afford to wait
so it would have been ideal to also have
the uk study results
before making this decision but that's
the nature of a pandemic
the science is changing all the time and
we have to make decisions
uh in the best way that we can with the
information that's available to us
there is growing urgency to get second
doses to manitobans the health care
system is struggling to deal with a
brutal third wave of infections
as brittany greenslade reports hospitals
are still overwhelmed
you were kind of kept in this area that
was completely plasticked off
you were curtained off you couldn't go
and see anybody
only the nurses came in or the doctor
came in it was maria nichols worst
nightmare
just days away from her vaccine
appointment she ended up in hospital
isolation with covid19
as her concerns for herself and her
husband who also had the virus
grew am i going to end up taking him to
emerge
because he needs a ventilator like we
both had the same
concerns and the same fears that you
know it's going to get worse and
i feel consider myself very fortunate
that it didn't
but so many others were not so lucky
manitoba's icu's are seeing
unprecedented surges of patients over
the weekend the province hit another
unfortunate record milestone 30 coveted
patients were admitted to icu
within a 48-hour period it's
disappointing
discouraging to have these numbers
so high it's exhausting and
it's stressful so we worry about
sustaining them
long term and it's becoming impossible
to keep up
so far 40 manitobans have been
transferred out of province for care in
ontario
and saskatchewan icu's the intensive
care unit staff is completely
exhausted and especially mentally
exhausted to move
a number of patients per day which is
unheard of for us in our intensive care
to ship out of province
you know more than one person a day so
the whole endeavor
is really very taxing and quite
extraordinary
doctors have been calling for a complete
lockdown to not just stop
cases but help health care workers who
are on the brink of breaking down
we have absolutely over taxed our icu
staff
i shudder to think of what happens if
they if some of them
start to give up because they're really
it's been a long haul
one that right now has no end in sight
brittany greenslade global news winnipeg
the world health organization has
unveiled a new naming system for all
those covid19 variants
the agency says it's now using letters
from the greek alphabet
so alpha is the new name for b117 first
identified in the uk
the b1351 variant first detected in
south africa is now beta
p1 is gamma and the variant first
detected in
india is now called delta the who says
it wanted to make all those names easier
to remember
and wanted to reduce the stigma of using
country-based
labels in vietnam authorities are
tightening restrictions after detecting
what they call
a very dangerous hybrid variant the
country's health minister says the new
highly transmissible variant appears to
be a combination
of the alpha and delta variants first
detected in the uk and india
it may be partly responsible for the
country's spike in cases
vietnam had kept lumber numbers low
throughout the pandemic but
international flights into the capital
are now suspended
and a mass testing campaign is underway
in ho chi minh city
ahead why israel's political rivals are
banding together to
unseat the prime minister
the longest-serving prime minister of
israel is on increasingly
shaky ground rivals of benjamin
netanyahu are joining together to form a
coalition to unseat him
they are not political allies and have
little in common except their desire to
no longer have netanyahu running the
country
crystal gomencing looks at the political
upheaval underway
in israel tonight after 12 years in
power
benjamin netanyahu has mastered out
maneuvering his opponents
but his reign in israel may be coming to
an end
so i think it's a very dramatic moment
for for israel
and politics and for bennett himself
he's taking a huge gamble
this man naftalny bennett a far-right
politician announced sunday
he's joining forces with centrist yair
lepid
to dethrone netanyahu god willing
together we can rescue the country from
its tailspin and return it on its path
it's a path full of roadblocks according
to lapid but one the country
needs to travel in tacoma
if this government is formed he said the
key word will be
responsibility to take responsibility to
restore
inner calm not blame others not look for
enemies
after 11 days of bombings that killed
more than 250 people
most of them in gaza a ceasefire is
holding
allowing the opportunity for this new
coalition
but this expert in middle east politics
says it will be difficult to form
government
because several small parties with very
different
views including the united arab list
will have to work together that's not
the same that the arabs
in israel will have a greater say in
politics but they will at least be at
the table
while many would like peace as the main
focus agreeable
domestic issues will likely take center
stage
but the ultimate goal for this coalition
should it
form is to oust netanyahu and see him
face corruption charges which he's been
fighting for years
the deadline to present a new cabinet to
the president
is wednesday night crystal gamansen
global news
london
leafs versus halves up next the
electricity ramps up for a classic
canadian rivalry
it will be a nail-biting night for habs
and leafs fans they go head-to-head
tonight in game seven of the playoffs
and a lucky 550 fans will be there to
see it in person
in toronto they are fully vaccinated
healthcare workers
it's not clear if they'll all be
cheering for the leafs but with the
history that team has in the playoffs
they can use all the help they can get
here's eric sorenson
hoping for the best it's uh got a lot of
nerves you know what i mean
every leafs fan knows what alex rennie
means the fear that this could happen
one more time
two straight overtime losses puts the
toronto maple leafs on the cusp of
adding another chapter in its saga of
sports futility
they've not won a playoff series in 17
years and it's been
54 years since this 1967 was their last
stanley cup
fast forward half a century with a bevy
of stars and veterans
expectations to end the drought have
never been higher this is the season
that
everything seemed to be going right for
them they had great scores
they it just seemed like the year of
destiny it's been a year unlike any
other
played in empty canadian arenas until
saturday's game in montreal welcomed
fans
and now toronto is doing the same for
many something more meaningful is
happening off the ice than on
550 health care workers fully vaccinated
attending the game
in person a way of thanking frontline
workers for their courage and hard work
during the pandemic
and a sign that life in this country is
getting back to normal and patel is a
nurse
and thrilled that health care workers
were picked to be in the stands
absolutely and we were all of us want
that because we are tired of this
pandemic the healthcare workers deserve
it i mean they've
what they've been through this last year
and changed it's uh it's unlike anything
we've ever seen as thoughts turn to the
game the two canadian teams with the
longest history will engineer one more
memorable outcome for montreal a win
would be a sweet surprise
for toronto an end to a legacy of
playoff failure
a loss for the leafs could change the
fortunes for everyone from management to
the coaches to the players
this game is probably the most important
franchise
game in the last several decades but for
leafs fans this is no time for pessimism
it's game seven game sevens are always
unique so long as uh
we play a good game i mean you can't
really ask for more well the leafs could
ask to win a playoff series for a change
eric sorensen global news toronto and
that is global national for this monday
i'm donna friesen tonight's here at
canada is island lake
in alberta thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow
bye